this is a production of Cornell
University
you
and interactions of incest
so work in the lab environment in
general it's gnarly thought I would sit
in
the evolution and ecology of veterinary
I interacted with us
yeah this is in particular I'm
interested in how the bacterial genome
contents Jam protec connects to
interactions with hosts or in different
environments and in particular this is
interesting for bacteria that interact
with multiple hosts or in multiple
environments that might be at the
current biotic environment or bacteria
that interact with a host and then also
with other a biotic environments and as
many of you know 2-20 is a really good
example of that because it does and have
that a lot of different environments a
person's very well studied as a plant
pathogen for good reason it's very
common plant pathogen that likely
infects possibly every player or nearly
every plant species is also a serious
ira cultural pathogen that was serious
like a cultural losses such as
inspector tomato or key we can take our
ornament highly virulent strains that
affect plants but additional to that
affected to that your apology
stirring a are what we what we call
surrogates a very diverse group of
strengths that probably the love which
are not very closely related to each
other and can happen a lot of different
habitats it could be more affectionate
we found a new Twitter and Hillary at
the water cycle so in the present and
lakes and rivers and actually rises up
into the atmosphere via evaporation and
transpiration and it's not to be a major
leader in biological nuclear and
occasionally falls down so it will be
very common in those environments
they're going to also be common on
plants without causing disease either
because of a plant that's not compatible
host or because it's simply epiphytic on
the surfaces
and we think it's on this context
population spec charity our pet services
with offensive suited for their worst
insects so a couple of years before a
certified postdoc work on this there was
one papers showing that
back to throw over them and then kill it
of having one additional habitat to this
party or the precipice the potentially
surveyed would be using athens as an
additional medicine post and will let my
postdoc work is focused at least
equestions
and defining what the effects of the
bacteria army that it's at coasts work
and also this might interest in trying
to connect genomes to bacterial colony
to figure out what the basis for these
interactions actually is and i'll be
presenting mostly this work today and
getting in a little bit to the direction
that going now as we're starting up work
here in the lab just putting this in a
broader context and understanding how
these interactions with insects that
actually be impacting actually
so most of the work that I've been doing
has been focusing on work life scissor
blowing people insects today and cert
they're sprawled like knock marks into
plants and perhaps out there also major
agricultural pests and they because they
can cause a lot of prop damage there's a
lot of interest and alternative control
strategies such as biological control or
bioactive compounds for the vessel
total my stuff so that's probably why I
focus and highlight that dress unless
they talk about the agents today but
actually fairly similar effects
so this is showing survival of cave-ins
and white flies that have been exposed
to two different strengths as soon as
year and a half of our surrogate
strength be 728 and our Tomatoes
Frankie's thousand I'm mostly going to
be talking about those strains today
this pattern can divide a little bit
so the dashed lines are white flies and
the solid lines are APIs that's showing
a proportion of individuals surviving
over time so these images have been
exposed to the bacteria and artificial
diamonds and bacon plants out that they
can feed off
without the insight and the treatment
see there were controlled which is
buffer added or bacteria that some kind
of effectual suspension added to the
plant
and as you can see the APIs in the white
plants have pretty similar decreases in
survival with both of the strengths with
e720 a you see a very impaired all that
response where in the insects survival
goes down to almost zero within just a
few days or a TC 3,000 survival is
significantly decreased compared to the
controls but not of the same
and I found this to be true not just in
hey that's my class but also in other
species and other ancient species you
see the similar highly virulent effect
with the heavy barrel on strains and
also have found fairly broad effects
across other unrelated insects so for
instance I would be did an experiment
will recommend lady evil our boat with
either infected or unexpected events and
the little survival was infected Athens
and their rate of development was slow
so it wasn't quite the same they weren't
there wasn't as airline doesn't store
for instance where they were all dying
but there was definitely an effect we
also found an effect and a lot of dr.
Marber
so I chewing herbivore that was heating
through that had natural natural numbers
of bacteria where the survival of the
larval secrets and velvet
so it seems like there could be fairly
broad effects of soaring across
different insects although a couple
varies depending on the insect is the
only insect that actually is something
that I can affect for is replies the
sample and Esther don't care
it doesn't apply through design but I'm
just saying they all of these insights
we've actually been covering survey
in fact they can see
his potentially eating plan and in fact
it might be a fairly broad cutter and
across other plants estimated bacteria
that we just haven't found yet so there
were actually been four plant pathogens
so that they had also been creating the
dungeon so these other three
Sergei where they grow inside the etc
so it's possible that these plans
bacteria are actually coming captain
Sykes but we don't really have a handle
on how frequent these interactions
actually are
and this leads into this broader
question of how environmental bacteria
actually impact in depth during sex
so mostly insects like aphids are
studied for their intracellular some
ions as you know are incredibly
important
but they are fairly limited
take an eight-bit simply sterilize that
event
our culture dependency will try to
affect you're gonna have another cut you
don't mind very much you guys like a few
texts out of yourself
people
there's not very much actually are there
and these have about communities
that's important
it also been for you know bacterial
pathogens other than the water side that
I showed you and it sounds really clear
if that is because this is the actual
pattern of these environments make sure
you're interacting with insects that
much or it's maybe an observation price
so with the
it's ineffective by stirring a they
don't have any obvious symptoms so
there's a lot of fungal pathogens of if
it's a and C wedding it's the
effectively for the captions for the
strokes I would be
without this you don't see anything they
got from the bacteria they just my
doctor it's also potentially hard to
find the infection in nature because
like so quickly so you need to kind of
kept in our example an April that would
be infected to catch it before the
vector George watched and it dies so
it's a kind of gives sense of how
frequent these interactions naive we've
done some work in the lab and
particularly looking at activity of days
so how many cells does the maintenance
to pick up at her apartment this is an
experiment
and this this experiment we used be some
in 48 days so he is to hide the mineral
trying to the would be shirt that a
strong effect and we did
in artificial diets and control exactly
how many bacteria
and we expose them to your varying doses
it was the second and third and starting
that so these rates that are still
developing they're not reproductive yet
so that things that they are
we affected them for 24 hours and that
attack gnomes or additional five days
with the mud sterile diet so now they're
actually been affected their diet itself
and we tracked their survival at the end
we tested to make sure that we knew
exactly when federal dose was and we
tested those diet
and we also a proportion of some of the
individuals and samples of perfection by
that working portion for actually
and this is replicated three times when
1340
and it turns out the mortality is no
cependant which is kind of what you
higher density to a healthy but
probability survival and
and the likelihood of infection also
increased as a vector of their so higher
doses
the log of the Metro
let's you a higher proportion of
infected
and the higher infection likelihood led
to decreased survival
so that means that the mortality is
actually correlated with the chance of
the likelihood of infection
so rather than it's not the number of
cells here picking out the matters for
whether you can conduct
effective publicly and in fact it seems
that you can become infected with a very
level number excels so here we have the
proportion surviving together over the
proportion effective and each point is
dose and we calculated the number of
cells occurs quickly and Justin based on
how much they were feeding
so the blue line is the control survival
these are all of doses that didn't
significantly alter the survival and the
red dots are all versus instability very
survival of the enzymes so in these two
cases these two
kids were likely only adjusting one to
themselves it had significant increase
survival and this is actually in keeping
with what was found in another system
and India were these different methods
to figure out what the effective
about ten cells so if the agent
a small number of bacteria those can
grow and they die
and Christmas is definitely indicated
like the proton heat protectants the
support in floral context suggesting
that this would be something that's
actually happening we've also done
experiments on plants testing the same
here the plants themselves were sprayed
with different types of bacteria and
then the aprons were introduced on some
plants that have been found in Harlan
County and at the end of the time we
the survival - horrified another
bacteria the wrong
so aptly when populations are at times
before our census
that's pretty Clips problem there was
significant
and the aptitude of rescission
population uh personally could actually
find uh please
this was done in a greenhouse that
imagine happening in nature and in fact
we see infection rates on plants without
10 to 30 percent of these it's becoming
so it's somewhat a significant effect
here where a lot of Ages of potentially
getting more perspectives suggesting
that this could be common to nature
and that raises the question of if
there's these kind of the gorilla
pathogens out there that they're
encountering frequently what are they
able to do enter the deadly sauce
we haven't done anything with
myths are thought to have a reduced
immunity compared to a lot of other
insects they have a lower number of I
mean questions in our genomes and for a
lot of packages they don't really about
as much as my main system compared to
what we expected my based on other
systems like the South Lawn so it's kind
of thought that Athens maybe don't
respond logically it's not that maybe
they have more very no ideological
defenses
one of possibility is by immediate
mediated immunity so intercellular
symbiotically defensive against
pathogens that can help the execs found
survive capture infection and rebounds
actually avoid flats but another
possibility of approaches
so if we're going to be compensation as
when there's a reproductive response to
to an infection and very individuals and
invest in reproduction over-investing
and immunity and that might be favored
when a original size of your work so if
you're not going to survive an infection
they're having a party trying to fight
it off and maybe you should invest less
of your resources and just reproducing
particularly if you are an organisms
that reproduce a lot so if those are
asexual and have really high
that's it
so to test this yourself an experiment
similar to the one with these
before 5:19 except this time we used
ec2000 because with the Lower Parel and
strains and this'll kill the insects
actually followed them long enough to
Washington reproduce so then the insects
were infected in artificial deities and
different writers of bacteria it said
after they were effectively put about
plants if they could going to be happy
as happy as it
and we tracked their survival
development track and reproductive rate
or
I was gonna give you the answer to what
happens to survival a development time
for survival
it was no stupendo as I saw with the
other strains so with higher doses for
Rory this time there was no effect on
development time they reached adulthood
equally fast if they were affected or
they are
we did see an interesting effect dr.
gray
so this is showing the number of
offspring per 1/5 per day and that's
your concentration of the location on
the x-axis so each point isn't it a
represent living at the rock pit and we
have three represents these are the
controls for all of those are all and
custard
the extremely high doses are over here
mostly those infants died before they
got a chance to reproduce
summers are so low and with their many
points you see a significant positive
correlation so there's actually a
decrease in reproductive rate with a
very low dresses
and these rates are it's rare than the
controllers
so this suggests that maybe there is
some kind of process to infection that
might be lowering their reproductive
ability
here but possibly there
increasing that reproductive rate to
cover the infection at possibly
and when you look at that if you look at
the it means other reproductive break
great justice down
none of these reproductive rates are
actually significantly
control but you can see
fact that the low-dose there's something
different happening
and that's particularly striking when
you look at the survival of the agents
at the same time since never gave
risotto surviving on
with all of these accessory producing so
these kind of since there's less than
20% of Athens actually surviving but
they're really introducing a break
we thank the legend of the Caribbean
that those
the black circles are reproducing faster
than the
collection actually a since after
infection and then that starts to go
down whereas the patrollers
are just starting to
it's having about reproduction to
counter the infection one success
about so this is some suggestion that
Athens may actually be reacting to two
barrel infections
we also have been exploring another
potential to be avoided so if there are
extrange out there that are highly
airline it would make sense if it's for
insects in general that evolved to avoid
them so this was work that was actually
done by an artist student in the lab
here Rachel
they are a student for the vector
girlfriends the pro programs in the
summer we were excited about how well
this worked out visually was able to do
three different experiments looking at
how to reggae influence david feeding so
the first experimented feeding rates on
artificial diet with or without
different bacterial strains now
and no choice so in this
in a setup where all they have access to
was an exception and it either control
or have bacterial suspensions in them
and they either had a choice about me
and she followed them for 24 hours
checking every few hours to see how many
larketa and a separate experimenting
with their feeding preference so this
setup they because were three
actually at a 96-well plates and eat
well to be a
by choice in a bacterial strain or
control and the agents were free to roam
around know where they were and she
looked again at commentators competing
over time and of course what we're most
interested in is whether this actually
works on plants so we also did an
experiment where they were given a
choice there are plants there different
recipe and leaves that have been sharing
our warranty
and this is being a father planted
version really nice setup for that
because as me as the leaves kind of a
pearl each leaf is suppose
they're about the same size so we
pointed one leaflet with that a bacteria
and the other mechanically control and
let those dry they made you receive is
on fire
so we did find an effect of be 720 a day
the Phoenix is fortunate of a good in
each cup that are that are feeding
either on control diet diet with
the control of these
yes and you can see that in the in the
control and be seen there's all the
exits
and this one's up when you actually get
a choice between different Wow
so in here there was less feeding out of
these three 2004 cares conventional
although it wasn't significantly
different and
Oh
you might notice that there's people
over there secondly a lower rate of the
overall here compared to what I just
showed you where almost all of the ages
of being here
it like this might be a difference just
in the experimental setup these were in
a different container they're not bigger
it might also be because they have this
had more spaces that didn't actually
have children
they just
that might actually be an effective of
that being
bacteria eventually if they found the
spot initially that had bacteria and
that we did
either they might move out or try to
find other places or just again some
more time
we at the end of this experiment we also
wanted to confirm that they
right bye
we found a low rate of affection 37,000
actually originally a fire
that were affected with me some
I should say that our ability to detect
a very low infection if there were just
we brighten it up and played it out
and if there's a couple of cells
but I think this it's writing it that it
matches these results really well and it
also suggests
actually actively avoiding that you
better what strength this is not
perfectly necessarily if they might
become infected with the 720
quickly and then stop eating because
or if they're actually the encounter
piece
and then I'm going to show the results
of our experiment area we've only got
this one
it is in keeping with what we found and
that the there were at least twice as
many a good speed and without bacteria
and apparently as with bacteria and this
is
which makes sense a bizarre-looking
around very much once they settled that
it seems that they were making some kind
of choice initially
so my thesis alter suggesting in keeping
with this idea that there are broad and
potentially there were virulent effects
on the insects the fact that lifter
insects die vertically for disinfection
when he bites
as well and also we're finding that
there might be a bit more complicated as
behaviors such as a reproduction or
feeding a part of things that we care
about because also respect to plants and
I'd like to be able to
you exploring this before getting a
better sense of what exactly was XR but
I'm also interested in being able to
figure out what the genomic basis of
these interactions
and so this session has been looked at
in Turin gay or even in Kerala couple of
different ways and the initial work that
people are initially about seventy years
ago
it's rained on number
barrels and they weren't able to find
something that
girl inspector that's it
but they did find that knocking out
swarming motility and certain area
impacted Maryland's important in some
way we've also tried some targeted
knocking out of genes that look like
I'm so sorry
lots of genes that are
this and that because that has no effect
we also Ida started kind of screening
all of the pieces that I could get my
hands on that were mostly use for
regulators
no effect there either and as I seen a
segment that was said to be a
relationship between guerrillas penalty
had sex sentences of something different
happening at this
so this
these are just what we like working I
try to different
get in
in this case
there are large numbers of surrogate
genomes and a lot of phenotypic
variation between strains to do a
genome-wide Association study so the
idea here is that you would have strains
with sequence genomes that very very
somewhat have hi girls
take all of their freaking sequences and
cluster those into their clusters my
mouth hurts and I'd love to see what
Cod's are present in each strain and how
that correlates with their virulence so
you would do a correlation between the
strength and effectiveness nice heroin
and the abundance of ACOG but each
strand has so I'm going to present the
results of this work
I only have 12 strains that I've been
it's actually happening here in order to
just
bringing in 214 strains that have
sequence to notice and actually
strengthen for the whiteflies the roads
so these strings are pretty broad swath
across those are engaging that are
biologically moving
so there's definitely a lot of
phylogenetic breath community and I'm
going to show you here on Stata for all
of these strands just it's a good sense
of how about varies across traits but I
actually only included strength in the
analysis which I have to regroup with
the assets
this train is hard and as you can see it
varies quite a bit so that the most
virulent strains have first be some
twenty a day which we talked about
before and actually to strengthen our
plant pathogens to help too
this fear the strength of generals head
I should say that Maryland's here I'm
measuring at the time that it takes for
the bacteria to significantly decrease
survival compared to controls so here's
all of the strands for one factor and
one eventually
and what difference is hopefully that
how
so this is just one measure of errands
but I tried with a girl incentive her
bed right
result regardless so I just like this
across France
so I'm taking the style taking all the
strange words I had good
I buster the protein sequences
and that did a correlation of the number
of genes in each with the virulence of
another given strength and so the
cinavia mirror identified candidate
genes that are correlated with parents
either because they're present in highly
rural chains of absence and low variance
I like more copies in high
and what yeah this is some example
patterns that you see
it
we're highly realistic
and a lot of pieces
copies and when you actually look to see
what those jeans are unfortunately our
jumper
there was one regulatory gene
transcription
transition
might be extinct that's changing
transcription across words there was a
human access to pass
transaction protein that I was
interested in because
and then a couple of other genes that
you know their function but it's not
entirely clear how that
in fact these are these are genes that
are correlated with Marilyn
actually positive there is likely items
told from the fight
strings are
there
and put some of these James
not related to the effect at all I
instance a lot of the
two are more commonly epiphytes that is
entry to game that this means that
they're more likely to incur the insects
but it also might just be a coincidence
whatever makes you a bit of a plague
they also make me barrel into incense
and I'd like to be able to get at that
question of is this just a coincidence
or are these strings actually adapted
for ignorance
insects
and the six of my larger question of
understanding how these interactions
impacts immigrant populations and
that you actually benefit from the
insects at all or they get it
first porousness actually didn't
our host within a few days
is that something wrong and
theoretically input we know that the
venture girl really kind of burst inside
the insects that this is data from white
flies these white mice were infected in
for 24 hours so that take it off the
diet act allows the bacteria girl inside
for both strains
you get some more actually a higher
number some cases be able to figure the
white flag necessary Benton's more drugs
their dependents
it sells for a bit which is
and I know that those that you are
currently treated anything funny do
honeydew is that kind of a picturesque
forward it's a anemic face
insects have threats up and they excrete
all that extra sugar it has really
shouldn't rich liquid and infected
agents in secrete a large number of
bacteria so 17 is all found that
infected even
ten to the seven co2 per square
centimeter of bacteriology and he
hypothesized that could be worth of
bacteria in Seville
population
to me about the case because it might be
good officially
sugar source but as that honey deserts
dry out the leaves and the osmolarity
changes through that in confession air
of a bad environment
so look at this we were interested in
looking at the
so we took the infected athens we've
collected their money dear over the
course of 24 hours and that's fine with
25 the number of bacteria that work
better than the different communities
for an additional 24 hours
so this is showing the change in veteran
population
after that innovation compared to of the
initial numbers were
for me
and the full changes on a log scale
because there's a lot of variation zero
would mean
numbers are about the same as they
initially were calculations say the same
and -1 would be all the bacteria time so
you can see that 50 and 75 percent
let's do very well actually that's when
you get up
so at very high communities especially
there may also be differences between
Australia
had hired me
although there's a lot of overlap here
but again reinforcing this question of
whether and interacting
are they going to do better if they're a
pissant plan that there's honeydew pink
nightgown or is that actually a bad
environment and look at this we set up
an experiment where we sprayed a
technicians at 7:20
and then we ate introduced aprons our
parents more ornaments we
beyond plan
we sampled a pathetic battery on the
plants and modified veteran populations
so this is just the results of one
experiment so in Sullivan primary but as
you can see the bacterial numbers were
higher at all communities
very high it was actually significant
there was overlap yeah
about a variation
but after the means our our point
difference in the log scale
it's not clear to me if this difference
is necessary
the Becherer were growing and the
or maybe they are driving
what I showed you before and defeated
so I don't know that that pretty Taylor
believed necessarily
but that might be I like to it
better sense of magic
these actually are
so the answer that question do that
you're actually benefit from having
it's ex-president answers sometimes
depending upon the environmental
conditions or possibly Isis
and we're going to keep working on using
experiments to really understand what
those conditions are what the
environmental evaluations are hard
constraints react to the subtraction and
how are actually impacting the bacterium
and all together put me in both sides of
this room
that's heroes like we're getting is that
they're very complex dynamics and how to
engage and interact settlements but also
with other
direct impacts by the survival of
interrupting taxes
you know that
leaving
the populations and then but we're
trying we're hoping to get a better
sense of how or think it all
and that ideally I'd like to be able to
conduct you what we learn about the
ecological interactions to about origins
not just looking at is
but moving to my collection
bacteria that they're avoiding if they
are pointing them or what bacterial
transfer necessary
growth time the ether or I
habitats
so those are some of the directions that
the lab is going I just wanna thank some
people at my previous Cossack labs and
university
here
and
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu